Hey everyone! I'm in Shibuya, Tokyo now. So, I'm going to do a brief tour of my hotel room.
I need to put this card in here so that the light stays on.
Otherwise, it's going to turn off on its own.
So first I'll do a quick 360.
And then there's a little bit more back there.
So I'm going to go to the... This is just a small restroom.
We have a sink here.
Hi.
And, as you may know, Japanese toilets are extremely high tech...
...where you can get various flushing sound effects, make the seat warm,...
...all that kind of interesting stuff.
So, on the other side, there is the closet along with the fridge, tea sets, etc.
And continuing on, here is, I guess, the living room kind of space.
We have a very long couch right here.
And then, the chair, comfy chair and a table with some paintings...
...and I love those lights.
Here's my luggage.
And then here I have my desk, where I'm probably going to be doing some desk work or makeup.
Here's the TV. I'm going to angle it towards...
...my two beds that I have here.
And then this is what the bathroom looks like.
And then over here,...
...since we didn't have a shower earlier or a bathtub in the restroom,...
...it was actually over here.
I love Japanese baths because they are very deep,...
...even though this doesn't look as deep in this video,...
...but it was really a nice way to relax and refresh myself for the next day.